any gel i'll go to i get a phone i'll
get drugs i can get a knife anything you
want so when i had a phone people just
say oh make their funny videos make fun
of it i will do funny videos next minute
i don't know how famous i was when i was
in jail you know what i mean but people
say liquor man you are you are viral out
there i'm thinking how they're like you
did you and your gangster major in
prison you know i mean giving it 10
stacks you know i'm saying
[Music]
what was your relationship with your
parents like
my dad was in poor drug and poor
he'd done 10 years in panama then
that's why i never had that father
figure so that's why i was on a rocky
path you know what i mean it was just me
and my mom and my two sisters
can you tell me about your childhood
what was it like
it was all right it was um
i used to go to primary school in rugby
um i was there to like was it
what's this i remember was it
year six
and i got kicked dogs i brought cannabis
into the school
tried selling cannabis got kicked out
there then i started going to you know
the naughty schools you used to go to
and whatnot well this this is can i
start again start getting that again
yeah
yeah
um i went to us um primary school and
after that i went to boarding school my
mom sent me to boarding school in
scotland
so yeah it was a bit
of a matter of roughy patch
why did you get sent to boarding school
snowy little sh
i don't know what to say that it was a
bit mad because obviously i was the only
black person there you see because this
is scotland cumbria i remember my mum
used to drive where we said we're going
to look at school i remember i was in
this cab for like four hours and i was
like hey where are we going and
obviously when i got there with some big
massive mansion just full of white
people no one out there's no colored
people there
it was just me i got dropped off mum
drove off left me there i was an aggie
person from a young age because i've
never had that father figure you're not
me so i just wanted to do what i want
and
it was just me i was young and i was
about 10 years old is this mad
how where are others treating you
there is because i was small and i was
different is a bit
they were they liked me but they were
goosey i don't know man it's hard to
explain i don't know what they were
thinking in their head you know i mean
and how much did you know about dwarfism
whilst you were growing up
uh
nothing really because i've never been
around small people i've never been
associated around small people you know
what i mean no one in my family's [ __ ]
dwarf physical controls yeah
no one in my family
obviously small people people are
country players they've got big bombs
big heads and small limbs in it so
obviously i can know i'm different
when and how did you get into crime from
there
it was just the people i was working
when i went to boarding school i was
there till i was 13. i don't know i
don't know robbery up there because we
used to when we used to come back you
need to get used to home leaves he used
to go home likes to get tobacco cannabis
whatever i can and bring it back and
when all the lads get back from their
families to back to the boarding school
we used to run away and just try to
escape and whatnot and obviously one
time we went off there's about 10 of us
we must have broken to one house one of
the lads killed a chicken
bear over madness and got bear drunk and
one of us had to get his stomach pumped
it was like it was crazy and obviously
they kicked me out of school for that i
went to court there and everything and
obviously ever since then i started
going in and out of prison from the
young age
how old were you when you first got to
prison 13 14.
how many times were you in prison in
general 14 times
not all together in and out in and out
in and out you know what i mean i was
high profile to the police i was my door
was coming off every day
it was crazy man when you think about
all of that time in prison what was live
there like well when i first started
when i first went to jail it was a bit
it was all right because it was everyone
used to love munich like all the big
like gangsters how you say it the
gangsters like they love me because i
was small and i was gangster and it was
it was different to them you know what i
mean so because i was small and i was on
it i didn't take notes from nobody they
were like yo you're with me you're with
us you know i mean no one could touch
you but you're not because obviously i
was getting too comfortable like that
all the big boys say yo little man just
calm down a little bit you're getting
too cocky you know i was like i'm
getting too comfortable and i'm thinking
no one could touch me you know what i'm
saying but i've had a couple of issues
in jail i've been stabbed in jail you
know what i mean i've it's just life and
it's what you go through but i'm just a
small man and technology from nobody you
know what i mean
did you ever feel that you were taken
advantage of yeah
a lot a lot of times
people used to make me do things i never
wanted to do this to miss make me rub
things and take the things off me
there's loads of stuff man you know i
mean back then i was young i was
vulnerable i had enough you know i mean
i was not i would say i was scared of
them because if i wasn't scared it
wouldn't happen you're not me so i'll
say yeah i'm scared of them because i'm
not like obviously licking my gangster
in jail obviously i'm well known in it
so any any gel i go to i get a phone
i'll get drugs i can get a knife
anything you want so it was just me so
when i had a phone people would say i'll
make their funny videos make fun of it i
will do funny videos next minute i don't
know how famous i was when i was in jail
you know what i mean but people say
little man you are you're viral out
there i'm thinking how they're like you
did you and you're a gangster major in
prison you know i mean giving it 10
stacks you know i'm saying
what kind of funny videos would you make
um i'll run across the floor like dog
i'll slap people with flour just bear
mad stuff jumping water it was just my
reckless stuff man it was crazy
[Music]
so when you got out of prison in 2019
what were you doing what was life like
it was crazy it was it was just
something different i've never i've
never you know i mean
it was so different because i've come
from a poor background you're not mean i
come from poverty you know i'm saying i
come from a council estate when i have
nothing i have to usually rob to get put
food in my mouth you know what i'm
saying it was just mad
you know i mean i come out of jail 2019
i got famous yeah thank you everyone but
yeah
you know what i mean you changed my life
it wasn't for them i'll be still in jail
in and out john i reckon but when i come
out of prison it was just like
lamborghini ferrari porsche outside i
was i was very confused because
obviously i don't know that life you
know what i mean all i know go rub this
and you feed yourself or go rub this and
put clothes on your back you know what
i'm saying like it was just crazy man
would you say
basically social media is what helped
you to get out of that of that life yeah
the fans have helped me because it
wasn't for them liking me and you know
etc i wouldn't be where i am now you
know what i mean but yeah the fame did
help me i stopped me because obviously i
got something to lose now before i never
had nothing to lose you know what i'm
saying i've got a beautiful daughter now
i've got you i mean i can't just do that
i can't follow my dad's footsteps
how did it happen that you got into
boxing because i've got a heart of a
lion here i don't care i've like
challenged anything my boy shaq come to
us and yo put him put him into boxing
because he can fight he's active you
know what i mean because obviously he
knows me because my good friend um we
got as we started getting into the
boxing thing the bounce was like are you
sure are you comfortable boxing that's
because
anything is challenged
what was your very first fight
um salim he's from french french blood
that was that i reckon that was the best
five i have ever had because he was just
me he was mad he was crazy
i loved every minute of it
how did you feel after it was
i was
i was i was upset myself thinking bro i
actually won you know what i mean
because everyone used to doubt me about
my young age i was like you can't do
that you can't do this you can't ride
this you can't shoot this you know what
i mean it was just mad
but when i won i thought yeah man
i'm a king of this i can do it
do you see yourself like as an advocate
as a representative for the people with
dwarfism what does that mean like well
basically the fact that you've made such
you've made a great career as a boxer
you kind of you you you broke out of a
life of crime do you do you think that
you're an example do you for of course
i'm a role model to them you know what i
mean like they look up to me everyone
looks up to me because because doing it
as well because i'm so small and i've
got confidence you know i went through
the craziest of life you know what i
mean so that's makes me the man i am
that's why i'm so
just
it's me in it
the crimes you've committed and things
you've been through how do you feel
about it looking back now obviously i
regret everything i've done but
obviously everything i did was for a
reason it's not just for because i
wanted to do it it's not just because i
thought i was a bad boy and i wanted to
break into this person's house or take
this person's team or put a knife on
this person it was not because of that
reason it was because i i had to do it
to feed myself feed my family or protect
myself or or someone made me do it you
know what i mean it was never because i
wanted to do it because i thought i was
bad or anything like that it was just
the lifestyle got bought up around the
gangsters i was around
i've never had no like my parents they
never taught me nothing can i mean it
was just eat sleep and [ __ ] you know i'm
saying get up go to school but i never
went to school so i would get kicked out
and that's why i got sent to boarding
school then i got kicked out of boarding
school then i started going to prison so
my prison my life was in prison i'm 24
may i can't go back to jail
i'm famous now i've got a good career
you know what i mean
what would you tell someone young
growing up with dwarfism now what would
you tell them what advice would you give
them
i'll tell the younger person that like
what was what's got controversial like
just i don't know man it's crazy man
just don't it's easy to say don't listen
to them just just get on with your day
and just focus on it just think about i
don't know man it's mad
because people take things different
when they take things to heart they you
know i mean they they will hold it in
the next minute they will just
blow it all out one is different man i
don't know man i don't know what to say
but what i'm saying is just if i can do
it you can do it you know what i mean
like
everyone's everyone's human and no one's
no different no one should be treated no
different everyone should be treated the
same
black white small big fat you know what
i mean all of that
what would you say to your fans out
there thank you very much for changing
my life for me because it wasn't for
them following me showing me love and
respecting me as me
i won't be with the situation with the
situation where i am now i'll probably
be still in and out of jail like an
idiot but
thank you very much and stay blessed
people
[Music]
i actually thought he was gonna walk off
and i see him look at me
and he he had a fault
and now i know what the fault was
i've got to kill him and he just walked
up to me and he just went
bang bang straight in the air